[Applause]
this
this movie is very this is an exciting
thing this is a beautiful thing this is
uh you steve harvey cedric the
entertainer right right uh d.l hughley
right correct
this is uh you guys are huge in the
world of stand-up comedy and you're
selling out arenas and they've made a
film about it you're saying huge
that's kind of scary huge i don't know
how to take that conan
well my opinion
my my opinion means very little
keep that in mind uh but uh well first
of all spike lee
right directed this movie it's basically
about you guys doing
your act why why did spike lee choose
this project because spike last five
films failed
this is better than clockers okay
no no he's going to edit you out at the
last minute but
i just get on the bus with spike i'm not
thinking about spike he didn't give me
that one line
yeah you know and he don't and he's
cheap
so you know he called me called me 10
times trying to get on this film you
know i wouldn't return his calls you
know right
i think spike was the only one really
that can really capture this
film the way it should have been right
because you know the essence of the
comedy of the four
individuals that's doing this comedy
he's the only one in my mind that i can
see that really can bring this film out
and grab the energy of it right now what
about of you four guys
who's the funniest
[Applause]
you know i got to be mentally challenged
to answer some stuff like that
like i'm gonna sit up i'm that stupid to
say cedric funny to me i'm not
damn funnier
i'm not going to sell myself no
all the guys are funny in their own way
and that's what made this tour so unique
right was because all of us are
headliners uh
uh dl cedric and myself and steve
we perform in large mass audience among
ourselves
so we combined all four guys their fans
came to see them
my fans came to see me so now you got
people who have never seen
either one of us right so we talking
about 24 000 people
right that is phenomenal these are huge
shows that is fun i mean
i was scared to death yeah and and steve
brought everyone out with all this
energy people running up and down the
aisle
one guy just vomited on the back of
another guy's neck
you know that sounds like the best show
in the world man i'm telling you
you can't beat it man i don't want
somebody has gone
to another level how many vomiting did
you have tonight we had 10 guys
that's a good show
that show was great
now you've been married you've been
married let's talk about your personal
life you've been married 25 years 25
years ago
woman same woman
i like how you have to say you don't
have to say to the same woman
i've been married 25 years yeah to nine
different women
you you got to say you got a claire [ __ ]
that listen to your every word
right right and 25 that's my high school
sweetheart
how do you keep things i'm just curious
i'm not married yet
thinking about that sometime in my life
how do you keep it fresh that's what
that's what guys who aren't married
worry about it how do you keep the spark
keeping it fresh you have to use your
imagination
and you keep some things to yourself you
know that's the key to the longevity of
marriage
i don't let my wife know that i look at
her as janet jackson
[Applause]
you know it's a lot of things i'm not a
genius conan
and i'm not a fool when i'm closer to a
genius
than i am a fool it's a good it's a good
theory you have there all right you just
don't
share with her though last night you
were yeah
you can't tell them everything because
no matter what you tell a woman
they don't listen they don't believe it
my wife gained weight since we got
married
and you know and and i sometimes i said
you look well no i'm not no i'm not you
know nobody no i'm not
i'm fat i'm fat yeah you are fat
[Laughter]
that doesn't go over too well right no
but you keep saying i keep telling you
you look well
you keep pushing it my mom said you know
you can't get in heaven telling lies
yeah you know so i told her the truth
tell her exactly the truth but it's hard
to see women because one thing i learned
25 years
women they don't want to be your your
your better half
they want to be your mama your doctor
your lawyer your pastor
your accountant you know they tell you
how to dress they tell you how to eat
that's that mother thing going to tell
you when to leave want to come and then
when
when when you when your love life
started demise a little bit
you haven't touched me in three weeks
where you know it's hard to make love to
your mama
yes it is
yes you know what i mean
[Applause]
i wish we had more time we haven't we
have no more time to talk you you got to
come back sometime because
there's so much fun stuff to talk about
you call my name and i'll be
it this is very nice for you the
original kings of comedy you have to go
see this opens
august 18th bernie mac thank you very
much that was great congrats
we'll take a break when we come back
terry mclean going to be here